hey 42 here you are born with 300 bones
in your body but by the time you are an
adult you will have 206 welcome to RIF
with an interior area 348 thousand
square feet the NASA vehicle assembly
building is so large that it has its own
weather system including rain clouds if
you could fold over a piece of paper 42
times it would reach the moon a blue
whale's heart is the size of a
Volkswagen Beetle and you can actually
swim through some of its arteries there
are more atoms in a single glass of
water than glasses of water in all of
the Earth's oceans of all the people in
history that have reached 65 years of
age half of them are living right now
Charlie Chaplin once entered a contest
for a Charlie Chaplin look-alike and he
came in third place falling out of bed
kills 450 people annually in the United
States the first man who survived going
over Niagara Falls in a barrel later
died by slipping on an orange peel if
you shuffle a deck of cards chances are
that the new order of playing cards has
never before existed and finally pirates
wear eye patches so that they can see in
the dark
when they go to a lower deck with poor
lighting they can simply remove the
patch and see better with that eye since
it's already adjusted to the dark
whereas the other eye will take several
minutes to adjust to the change in light
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you